when Guru sacrificed himself at the end
of Guardians of the Galaxy rocket kept a
small piece of his body and replanted it
causing a new sapling to be grown from
his previous form in the second
Guardians movie were introduced to a new
version of the character baby Groot Baby
Groot is smaller in size and often
portrayed as having a more innocent and
playful personality in Avengers Infinity
War we see Groot as a teenager showing
signs of growth and maturity as he helps
the Guardians of the Galaxy fight
against Thanos Tinker is more angsty and
Moody than his baby counterpart and he's
shown to be preoccupied with playing
video games the entire time this version
of Groot is in his young adult stage and
Falls somewhere between the previously
seen teen group and adult group he has a
little bit more of a sophisticated and
mature personality than his team form
while still keeping the charm and humor
that has made his character a fan
favorite adult Groot is the original
version of the character from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe he first appeared in
the movie Guardians of the Galaxy as a
mature and wise character King Groot is
a towering and sentient tree-like
creature from a parallel universe who
rules as the Invincible master of plants
and acts as the king of Planet X
standing at a height of at least 60 feet
tall